welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University
visit
we have the great honor of being the
last stop on Bill Gates's farewell tour
and in addition and most importantly
you're going to be in the presence of a
legend there are not many people have
changed the world as decisively as Bill
Gates has and they're fewer still who
have accomplished the kind of change
he's accomplished as rapidly
thoughtfully and purposefully you know
the story of Microsoft so I'm not going
to repeat it here it's just a remarkable
story the great one of the great
business stories great business
successes technology successes of all
time and a great example of technology
leadership Weah Carnegie Mellon have
enjoyed a long and productive
relationship with Microsoft one that is
existed for decades we have hundreds of
alumni and former faculty who work at
Microsoft in this room today there are
57 students to whom Microsoft has
extended job offers and now you know the
real reason for Bill Gates's visit here
today
I'm impressed he come out I come all the
way out here just to recruit you all
we're also very proud that we have 12
Gates Millennium scholars who receive
very generous support from the Gates
Foundation for their undergraduate and
graduate studies many faculty have
connections to the company and research
projects the company funds and of course
most difficult there's the gate Center
for computer science which is rising as
we speak and that was made possible by a
very generous 20 million dollar gift
from the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation in 2004 shortly after Bill
Gates his last visit so please join me
in giving a Kearney Mel and welcome to a
visionary computer scientist a brilliant
business leader the world's leading
philanthropist and a great friend of
this University
ladies and gentlemen Bill Gates
thank you
and very much
yeah I'm excited I'm excited to be back
here at Carnegie Mellon the work that's
going on here as as you all know very
well is is fantastic world-class work as
the president said Microsoft has been
very lucky to hire some brilliant people
from the University and we're continuing
that tradition this year with a great
new crop of people who are gonna do some
amazing work some of our top people
including a regression two runs
Microsoft Research Harry Shum who's got
the simple job of running the
development group that competes with
Google search and many others have been
at Microsoft a long time and already
made a huge difference in the work they
do we also have a great ongoing
relationship in terms of the research
that's going on here and I had a fun
afternoon meeting with the number of the
faculty hearing about their latest
developments talking about where things
are moving rapidly and how we do a
better job in computer science of making
it a tool for all the sciences how we do
a better job of using computer science
to reach out to people around the world
so that they get the benefits of the
very rapid innovation and so I know a
lot of those collaborations are going to
lead to great new products and a lot of
impact in terms of how technology gets
used so I've been looking forward to
coming here and but I want to talk about
mostly is where software is going and
some of the opportunities I think people
are even under estimating the impact of
software and some of the ways that it
can improve a wide range of things now
for me personally this year will be a
year of change this summer I switch from
being full-time at Microsoft to being
part-time there and from being part-time
at the foundation to being full-time
there and that's the first time I've
really changed my work focus since I was
age 17 and Paul al and I decided that
starting Microsoft would be a great
thing and in fact interrupted my college
studies at that time have resumed them I
don't know when I might although with
all these online courses now you could
say that I'm sort of back at college
because I'm a great consumer of online
courseware so anyway that the change
will be a new thing for me and I don't
know what it'll be like to have that
last day and and start up new things and
so a few friends volunteered to make a
little movie to help me get ready for
that so let's take a look at at what
they did it is a day the industry never
thought would come join us all day as we
report on Bill Gates last full day at
Microsoft it's been in the planning for
the past two years so still be active as
chairman it's hard to believe it's
really here yeah I think Bill's ready
for his last day
he's worked pretty hard saved a little
bit he is completely focus
I mean it's been going all-out for more
than 30 years so not having a completely
full schedule every day has been a
little well interesting never doubt the
magic of software that's right listen to
Tabaka you know after all these years
he's finally taking work-life balance
seriously he's even got a personal
trainer curls for girls curls for girls
if you wanna beat I am Oh
tuberculosis oh yes bye-bye tuberculosis
ahead but headbutt step on there we go
for yourself come on my lean a little
forward just think high H eye to the sky
you know
yeah Mills always been a bit of a ham
but more importantly it's the creative
risks you take that really set him apart
Big Pimpin I'm busy big yeah you know
Sydney got it kilt that Billy J hey let
me let me get one thing straight with
you you can retire and then unretire
exactly
it's got keep him guessing thanks Jay
now it was great
not so much I couldn't break his heart
though somebody gotta tell him it's
horrible
just taken hello bill
dude wasn't that the craziest rip you've
ever heard
positions are filled
Bill's always been a big fan of movies
but he's probably gone a bit too far
with this whole audition real thing yeah
bill I talked to Clooney
I talked to Clooney myself I had him on
the phone I heard his voice it was
George Clooney I helped put him in ER I
know George Clooney it's George Clooney
well fine
talk to them yourself I I heard no we're
just not doing in the oceans 14 that's
the well no but if we weren't doing one
then then we would hire you
yes we're just we're not doing what
right that's okay no no there's no we're
not doing a sequel to to see Rihanna
neither um everyone died hey I was
thinking about the last time I was on
the show I I thought it was really
successful yeah no you were great on the
show man we loved it it was although you
know you'd kind of run off at the end
like I you know had monkey pox
you know the only thing is billing on I
never said anything but you never gave
us our mic back and and I hate to say
anything but we only have three so no
there's never been any animosity between
the two of us about who's number one
who's number two I never give it a
thought
so when bill called and told me he
needed some temporary office space
during the transition I would let help
working on this new malaria vaccine the
interest we got one chili cheese one
bacon Chee to fry one onion ring to
dilly bars one I don't know all courtesy
of mr. Buffett and you didn't hear this
from me it's a pretty strange
coincidence that his transition date is
right in the middle of the 2008
presidential campaign I know you're
super busy but I I'm sure you're
starting to think about who would be
your best running mate no I I know I
haven't actually declared a running mate
yet bill but I'm not sure politics is
really for you hey it's bill
they'll share them but start talking now
the other bill Bill Clinton the man has
a tenacious work ethic no one is sure if
even sleeps I've always been a start-up
kind of guy so that's my next big idea
what do you think
well solar powered nano robots grown
from Justin Timberlake stem cells are
intriguing but they're really not my
area of expertise but we've got a new
partner here at the firm who I know can
help you out oh hey Bill
no it's not an inconvenient time yeah I
get it you know no that was a good one
the truck but you do of course we'll
miss him in the daily brainstorming
meetings he's always been an innovator
really inspiring all of us to think
creatively about the future and we'll be
the first to give credit where credit is
due
oh absolutely Microsoft Bob
his idea all his
like I said we've been planning for this
but he's still built and we'll miss
seeing him in the hallway every day
anybody see them on the board meeting
and all tech markets remain steady as
Bill Gates completed his historic last
full day at Microsoft personal note all
of us here at NBC News will miss
reporting every night on this brilliant
powerful let's face it sexy and
good-looking leader of men and women
just doesn't believe in paying more than
$7 for a haircut I'm Brian Williams in
New York good night
we had a lot of fun making that of
course I don't think I'll have too much
spare time with the ambitious challenges
of the foundation and I will continue to
work on some of the more exciting
Microsoft problems whether it's in
natural user interface that I'll be
talking about or areas around knowledge
management some some fun projects I'll
keep my hand in and then the the
full-time work at the foundation that is
very very ambitious so let's talk about
software why has it become so important
in how will that change when Microsoft
got started software was not important
computers were very few in number and
they were used by governments and large
organizations if anything they were sort
of against empowerment you were worried
it was gonna bill you the wrong amount
and you would staple the punch card and
try and mess up the big machine the idea
that this would become the tool for
creativity and collaboration and
communication the best tool that we'd
ever created and that as we connected to
them together a whole new phenomena
would develop around that that wasn't
obvious back in 1975 but Paul Allen and
I thought ok we'll do software we'll
build a platform and encourage other
people to write software now there was a
heroic assumption there that we could
get millions of machines out because
after all if you want to make it
economic to spend tens of millions
developing software and sell it for $100
or so you've really got to get that base
out there but because we made that bet
we got that going it became a virtuous
cycle that is as more machines would
sell it created the market for a broader
range of software and that further drove
the market for the machines and in fact
that volume allowed the price of the
machine to come down and that's why from
1975 onward that personal computer
market actually not only became
significant it actually became the
center of the entire
computer industry the large machines we
use today and the big server farms or
corporate data servers these are all
based on the Windows PC architecture
which because of its volume has come
down in price and improved in
performance very very dramatically and
so we have a large software industry
today
there's over a billion windows personal
computers and use there's about two
billion cell phones 20% of which you
could think of as a computing platform
but say in three or four years they'll
be about two billion of those that do
have the capability to run software
applications we have software that's
being used in the car we have software
that's being used in set-top boxes so a
wide variety of places where software is
employed today broadband connections are
only in 300 million locations we had a
million people having access so that's a
smaller number but the growth is very
very high in fact a few weeks ago China
passed the United States to become the
largest broadband market in the world in
because China has more people we're not
likely to catch up in fact in a couple
years to have more broadband users than
we have people so it would be very very
difficult I think that just emphasizes
that this is a very global market in
terms of the innovation the actual use
of the technology it is everywhere in
the world that it's making a dramatic
difference now why could we be so
ambitious and why is the personal
computer taking on more and more
activities part of it is the innovation
and hardware a key insight that got Paul
and I going was that Moore's law the
rule predicted by Gordon Moore said that
we'd have double the number of
transistors every two years and that
meant that we could dream about almost
arbitrary levels of computing power in
fact that Moore's law
looks like it'll continue out into the
future more than a decade but
it won't give us the same clock speed
scaling we've had in the past so it's a
interesting challenge of computer
science in terms of making it easy to
write params that run across the
multiple cores because that's how we'll
be using those extra transistors the
other aspects of computing the storage
capacity will also go up exponentially
exponentially the wireless and wired
connection speeds because of optic fiber
improvements and signal processing
improvements those likewise will have
the same exponential improvement so they
aren't holding us back in any way some
of the changes in it are more
qualitative than quantitative the idea
that we have high resolution so that
something like virtual earth can display
a 3d model of the world and you can walk
down the street point into building go
in see what's going on if you want to
buy books it doesn't have to be a 2d
format it can be the book store that was
created for you with books that you
might find interesting
because of what your friends are reading
or interest that you've shown in the
past so making 3d reasonable the refresh
rate the richness we're just at that
threshold the idea of screen technology
being inexpensive so that we can project
onto the walls and tables and any
surface that's out there in the home
environment in the office environment
there's breakthrough technology that
will be in the marketplace in three or
four years that will make that very
possible so whether it's your room and
you want to have a theme or the various
business data in the office all of that
can be displayed I think one of the
greatest changes that will take place is
the way that we interact with software
to date
that's overwhelmingly been through the
keyboard and the mouse the the pointing
device and I'm not saying that the
keyboard goes away it's a very nice way
when you have your hands-free you've got
the table to do it on a nice way of
particularly doing text oriented
activity but we're gonna complement it
with a variety of other interactions
capabilities and I talked about these as
natural user interface perhaps the most
simple of these is just touch I see with
the iPhone you see with
number of pcs out there the idea of
putting touch on the screen and making
that a way that you can interact as
simple applications is very very
inexpensive the next I'd highlight is
the pen this goes beyond touch in terms
of the resolution and capabilities here
you can take your notes in a meeting or
in a class you can look at an article
annotate it say what friend you'd like
to send that note off to very
straightforward natural thing and as we
get the hardware form factor this tablet
form factor that's light enough and thin
enough and has the right price and
battery life all the kind of reading and
note-taking activity will naturally move
to the digital realm we've already seen
many things that were done non digitally
that that have moved to the digital
realm the print based encyclopedia that
I grew up with the world book my friend
Warren Buffett and so on this is
basically obsolete today he says it
still smells good and I admit neither in
kardea or Wikipedia managed to match the
smell but it's it's a pretty good price
to get that feature so we've had a
transition the interactivity animation
timeline capabilities of that online
encyclopedia just blow away anything
that could be done in print and all text
books will clearly go that way my
daughter goes to a school where they
been using tablet PCs there for over a
decade and so they're one of the most
advanced at how you don't need that
paper textbook and some of the benefits
they've had in terms of their
instructional approach as they've
learned year by year by year are really
fantastic and not just in math and
science that quite across a wide range
of subjects they now have experienced
teachers who've really embraced this and
now that's spreading to many other
locations and that would be heightened
by the hardware and software advances so
I think the pen would think is a very
important form of interaction another
big one and this goes back to some work
done at Carnegie Mellon many decades ago
and continuing to improve is the speech
recognition capability
this is one of those problems where
computer scientists we're a little
optimistic we only missed how soon we'd
have it right by a couple decades or so
but that's okay what it speaks to is the
incredible recognition capability and
learning capability that humans have and
matching any of these human recognition
systems has just made us admire how
great those systems are but with speech
now in in known domains now the
quality's gotten quite good so we have
tell me software for example it runs on
the cell phone that can take a business
inquiry or search inquiry news inquiry
and respond to that in a very rich way
today that software handles the vast
majority of all directory assistance
requests in the United States and so
we're building up a database of what we
get right what we get wrong constantly
retraining it there will be hardware
improvements in terms of multiple
microphones that will help with the
various noise elimination problems we
have but constant improvement now that
we've hit that magic threshold we'd say
that there'll be more searches done
through speech than through the keyboard
five years from now and so it's one of
the big bets that we're making is
bringing that both to the cell phone in
and to the auto and to the living room
and to the PC environment is that speech
interaction you saw recently Ford in all
of their new models put in a thing
called sync which is a speech
interaction thing and I've been very
pleased to see the response to that The
Selecter music initiate a call even send
a simple text message that is a speech
oriented activity and so the foundation
of research over the last few decades
helped and and it's been refined and
refined and the power of the hardware
finally let us say that that is moving
into the mainstream there's another type
of natural interface that I think is
perhaps the most important of all and
I'll call it vision that is the cameras
that connect up to a PC are very very
inexpensive and the software algorithms
that are being worked on here and many
other great academic centers and
Microsoft Research and others is getting
better and better and better and so the
idea of recognizing gestures recognizing
individuals recognizing objects it's the
point where it's it's very effective and
so we're putting a product called
Microsoft service into the marketplace
it's like the table and when you put
your fingers down it sees what's going
on if you put a cell phone down it'll
realize that's what it is and try and
contact it with Bluetooth if you're
playing checkers it'll know or dice or
cards or anything
that might be fun to do it's seen what's
going on and so instead of talking about
a computer on every desk we'll talk
about a computer in every desk and in
fact every surface in your office or
your living room will be intelligent
when you go to that whiteboard and put
up the schedule for a project you
complained dive into different
milestones circle things put up a video
of somebody who you're engaged in a
telepresence conversation with all in a
supernatural way and the home
environment likewise organizing your
family photos or picking what videos
you're interested in are playing new
types of games where where have all that
surface area for display you can do
something quite immersive and and quite
fantastic all of that is very achievable
in the next four or five years and so
this surface type computing both
vertical which is whiteboard or an
intelligent mirror in your home I'll let
you think about some clever applications
for that I'm sure we won't think of them
all
it's a even more impactful form of
making computer pervasive having it be
everywhere and the software progress on
that problem is the reason that I'm I'm
so optimistic that that will come into
the mainstream so now if we think about
this in terms of different activities
I'm saying that information workers
workers who work in offices will be far
more empowered with information their
ability to drill down in today to look
at critical paths understanding what's
going on with their most important
customers collaborate with people at a
distance stay in touch under be alerted
when something's not working well take
their key objectives and have indicators
that
really keep them up-to-date about those
things themselves individually program
in little algorithms that relate to the
domain they work in whether it's
analyzing quality or looking at the
sales process all of these things will
be available to them and today they are
are only very partially empowered you
know a lot of their time is not spent
very effectively they don't see the
external data they don't see the
patterns in that data and so that
mission making people in the office way
more effective isn't nearly done and and
software is the thing that will complete
that and make those jobs not only more
effective but also a lot more
interesting as well if we look at
developers we still write code at a very
low level
it hasn't changed really for 20 or 30
years I mean we had Pascal and Fortran
even before I used computers we had
those things and we haven't we're not at
a level of abstraction where the data
models or the ability to make
declarative statements have really
gotten to be the way that say a business
would customize applications
big businesses today can have millions
of lines of code where the differences
between them could be described in terms
of say a hundred pages of English so
there's a huge explosion as you get down
into executable code that leads to high
costs long lead times difficulty of
proving that it's correct difficulty of
changing you know the number of lines of
code really is your enemy in every way
and so we need this model-based
abstraction again an area that a lot of
good research work has been done in but
now I think we really on the cost of
being able to say that businesses for
their kinds of applications will be able
to write about 1/10 as much code as they
do today now part of this is that the
computing environment they run in will
be far more abstract the idea of hard
disk failure computer failure that will
be abstracted away from them and it'll
be a layer below that's restarting
Reaper biting those resources and so
their code won't have to work
on those things whatsoever in fact for
an IT person who today is managing error
messages and moving files around or
which program runs on which machine that
will be a completely automated task both
in customer data centers and in some big
pool data centers that people like
Microsoft and others will provide I
often talk about these as mega data
centers because they are literally tens
of millions of processors and the whole
way that you architect servers and
storage and electricity and cooling is
utterly different as you move into that
realm of scale and in fact there are
great scale economics that can work in
your favor as you take advantage of
those new architectural approaches and
we're just scratching the surface even
the very chip designs themselves will be
influenced by how they should run in
this type of environment that's not to
say all the computing will be there we
need a lot of computing near to the user
to have these natural interfaces be
incredibly responsive and effective will
still have computing at the corporate
data center level but this cloud
computing will come in and be a very
important element both the computing
piece and the data storage piece if we
think of user activities in the home
environment that will also be very
different on TV today's passive channel
oriented type experience and we finally
gotten in about a million users
connected to TV shows through the
internet with partners like AT&T and
about 20 of the other big phone
companies around the world once it's
connected up that way the ability to
make the show personalized so in the
news segment you see the subjects you
care about more the subjects you don't
care about less if you're watching the
Olympics the sports that intrigue you
you can ask for more information on and
skip over things that are not of
interest to you game shows sports shows
educational shows can all be a lot
better advertising which is a the sort
of lifeblood of TV by being personalized
an interactive can also be more relevant
to the user and more beneficial to the
advertiser as well and so TV is on
the cusp of a big change we have the
best content providers around the world
now thinking through for each of these
genres how they take our toolkit in and
take their shows and present them in
this richer way and we won't have a
dichotomy between video on the PC and
video on the TV those two things will be
brought together so as we construct your
personal guide if we know that you have
a relative who's doing some sports even
if it's very obscure and a parent just
happened to take an HD camera and post
it to the web will know that that
belongs there on the list of things that
you might be interested in even
education itself which hasn't changed a
lot as we take and split education to
the lecture piece the study group piece
and the accreditation piece the first
and third piece the lecture and the
accreditation can be done on a scale way
already the very best lectures in the
world the video those are being put
completely online available to anyone
and it means students around the world
are coming up and accessing those things
you know I recently was confused about
solid-state physics so you know now MIT
doesn't even know it I'm taking a
solid-state physics course and it's
absolutely fantastic I watch it when I
want I do the homework problems I sent
email to my friends I get confused it
it's a whole new way of getting access
to information and thinking about these
these different elements and so I think
something profound can happen there as
well so software will change a lot of
our activities now software is becoming
important not just for these direct uses
which you'd think of okay this is what
the computer science department should
be doing programming data centers
natural user interface software is also
important to the other branches of
science they're dealing with so much
information that the databases the
queries against those databases and the
pattern the Machine the need for machine
learning to figure out what is going on
with that data is absolutely essential
we're talking this afternoon
about some work being done at this
university where a lot of people are now
focused on computational biology what do
those queries look like what are those
structures look like how many levels of
semantics are there in that without
software these problems are intractable
even a science that we had least I used
to think of as very simple astronomy is
now a data-driven science it's no longer
about being the lucky person was there
at midnight and was looking at the
telescope and something really cool
happened up there and you know you write
it up and you're a famous astronomer now
there's all this data various
wavelengths and various times and
whatever proposition you have about how
the universe works needs to be tested
against all that information and so
making it easy for a scientist anywhere
in the world to take data from any of
those telescopes or satellites and
various things and try out their ideas
that's an important foundation for that
science to move forward organizing that
information might be the most difficult
in biology because the range and the
amount is very tricky and one piece of
that is studying the brain now Microsoft
Research is trying to reach out not just
to computer science departments but
these other science areas as well and
have them tell us what they'd like
software to do in modeling and
visualization and data structuring and
use that to push the limits to help us
understand where new inventions are
necessary they the brain is a great
example of that so I want to show one
collaboration just as an example and
this is one I hope it's not politically
incorrect that's with Harvard and a
brain scientist there named Jeff
Lichtman so let's hear a little bit
about the challenge that he faces
I'd like to tell you today about an
exciting collaboration that's just
starting up between me and several of my
colleagues in the Center for Brain
science at Harvard University and
another group at Harvard University and
the initiative for innovative computing
with Microsoft we know less about our
brains actually than any other part of
our body and I would even go farther
than that I would say we know less about
our brains than anything that human
beings know about it's that mysterious
for us to understand many disease
processes and the way the normal brain
works we really need a wiring diagram of
a brain you would need a hard disk that
is approximately 1 million petabytes
many of you don't know what a petabyte
is I bet a petabyte is a thousand
terabytes a terabyte is a thousand
gigabytes so one human brain requires
1,000 billion gigabyte hard disks so
we're going to start even smaller than
that and look at a little cubic
millimeter of a mouse brain that's about
a petabyte of data that's almost
manageable today and we've built a
radically new kind of micro tone to
shave off one layer after another and
little volumes like that put them on
tape and then image them then we were
very pleased that Microsoft already has
developed several tools that are really
wonderful to get us started and I want
to start by showing you a demonstration
ok so I've got here on the screen now
this software called HD view that takes
that scan data that they have from the
mouse brain I'm sure you're all looking
forward to seeing the mouse brain and
puts it in a forum where people can
navigate through it and apply software
algorithms to finding out what's going
on dealing with images like this you
need you know high performance we make
it easy to get at zooming in panning
looking at it in different ways we could
also take these different
so that's the different slices layered
on top of each other I just focus on one
at a time you'll see it as I go layer by
layer I can see the different things
that are going on there you know
visually navigating and looking for
features as part of it but having
software be able to efficiently get at
the data is perhaps the most important
thing here we have software analysis
that went in and found various
boundaries in the different layers and
now it's trying to go layer by layer and
see how those connect together and then
it's able to recognize where the neurons
are how they connect up to each other
and then start to form a model of what's
going on in the mouse brain how it
changes over time what the levels of
functionality are obviously we're
decades away from the total deep
understanding there but it's going to
take software analysis and software
tools like this connected to those
domain experts in order to make the kind
of progress that we're interested in
that type of deep collaboration of the
software experts and these domain
experts is a real theme and you know I
know Carnegie Mellon has been a pioneer
in thinking about these internationally
problems how do you make sure that you
can expose people to enough computer
science and and have in one person a lot
of this knowledge and in groups that are
working together those capabilities it
really is a fascinating problem but a
necessary problem to solve it's almost
like mathematics was say in the early
1900s where the it became such an
important tool for describing what was
going on that people in the sciences
like it or not needed to become familiar
with those techniques and the real
breakthroughs in the 1900s across many
areas were partly because of those
mathematical representations I want to
talk now about a special issue in terms
of the impact that software might be
able to have and that is taking the
perspective of the six billion people on
the planet
and trying to look at how software will
impact the top third the richest two
billion the middle third the next two
billion and and perhaps most
interestingly the the bottom third about
two billion in some ways people think
well geez can't we just make things
cheaper and scale them down and that
will have a very nice impact on fact in
places where you don't have electricity
you don't have training you don't have a
schoolroom or a teacher it's not going
to have much impact the the needs the
problems the priorities are different
than simply saying hey let's just take
what we have and make it lower cost
making it lower cost is a fantastic
thing that's much more an issue though
for that middle two billion and the
industry's done a great job bringing
these things down it's really the
connectivity costs and the training
costs that denominating else the
hardware costs offer costs and all these
things the software's donated for these
outreach type projects the hardware's
gotten fairly inexpensive in fact we
have a cell phone now that you can
connect up to a TV set and get a large
screen display and so you're looking at
cell phone type costs even to do full
screen type applications but then you
know you still need somewhat of a
network we can often piggyback on the
cell phone network but there are cases
where that's not even there we think
what's going on with this the most
challenge two billion there's a variety
of things that have to do with their
farming production is very low 64
percent of these people are rural small
farmers the amount of nutrition they
have is very very low the level of
disease is very high we take the big
infectious diseases ninety percent of
the effect of these diseases is on that
bottom 2 billion in fact that's part of
the reasons why we have what I would
refer to as a market failure that is the
market directs itself to solve problems
based on economic signals and so the top
two billion can send very strong
economic signals a good example of that
is these top two Billy
they don't like being bald and so
billions are being spent on curing
baldness nobody's dying but boy they've
got their money out on the table and
that's great someday I think they'll
solve that the bottom 2 billion a
million children a year die of malaria
and yet there's less than 10% as much
put into malaria research as there is
into baldness research and you think
well you know is that appropriate or is
that a market failure how do you solve a
problem like that I'm not someone who's
suggesting that we mess up in some
dramatic way the incentive system that
it's done so well after all if we look
at the last 50 years the incentive
system we have actually has done very
well not for everyone
and we need to be aware of that but
broadly the fact you can even talk about
that middle to billion that is the an
incredible success story 50 years ago
there were the rich countries in the
poor countries and now we have a
complete distribution even within
countries we have a very interesting
distribution unfortunately if we look at
that bottom part there are a few areas
that are heavily represented
particularly sub-saharan Africa parts of
Asia but most of those areas have seen
rapid improvement you know if you take
out say Afghanistan and Yemen and you're
really looking at the toughest things it
you're overwhelmingly talking about
sub-saharan Africa so we need to do
something to try and get this innovation
to apply to these problems and I'm
really pleased to see that there is a
growing awareness of those problems and
a growing willingness to put energy into
thinking about them and thinking about
where innovation can help for myself I
grab a left the university without any
awareness of the conditions of the
poorest to billions if you'd asked me I
would have said yeah I guess they have
less food less electricity and things
but I didn't really understand the trap
that exists there in the the nature of
those
it was 15 years later that I was reading
a newspaper article that talked about
rotavirus and said it killed the half a
million children here and I thought well
what's rotavirus I've never heard of it
is somebody working on it well it turned
out at the time basically nobody was
because again it's a case where there's
no signal that says that's something of
importance and it ought to be pulled
together and so I think if you go back
ten years ago is very easy for somebody
going to college even somebody going to
a medical school where you think a lot
of these problems would be highlighted
in a fairly dramatic way it's very
possible not to know much about them I
think that is changing I see the
interest level of course the
availability through the internet to
learn about these things the desire to
get out and see some of these conditions
is much stronger today I was meeting
with some of the students who are
working on the the thing called tech
bridge here which is aimed at thinking
through what what are those needs and
where they can be addressed I've seen
some wonderful projects that are
actually out being out getting out large
numbers and sometimes they're not cool
because of the technology they're really
only cool because of the impact one that
I'll cite we call digital green and this
was done by our in your research lab
that has a particular focus on the the
needs of the they call it the bottom of
the pyramid those those two billion they
went out to these farmers and saw that a
direct use of computing wouldn't be
possible no cell network no electricity
and that the real problem you wanna
solve is the productivity the farming
productivity if you have a drought if
you haven't grown enough the season
before and then you literally face
malnutrition that has a lifetime
negative effect or in the extreme case
even starvation so they saw that there
were techniques that if these farmers
applied they could more than double
their output but the current extension
system just wasn't getting them
to them in the right way so the adoption
rates for typical advances among
smallholders was about 15% what they did
was they took the advanced technology of
DVD and they went out and took films of
the farmers doing it the right way in
local language brought those back edited
them took the best practices and hired
people who knew these farmers were
socially connected to them to go out
with a battery-powered DVD device and
show those videos and what they got was
a tripling in the adoption of these
farming practices and so a significant
impact in terms of the nutrition and the
ability to live through bad seasonal
effects in fact they even created this
wonderful dynamic that the farmers
wanted to be in the videos it's a lot
like American Idol but this is farmer
Idol you know I've got this technique
you got to get me on their competition
in something like that and say a
wondrous thing to see now that's just
one vignette there's a lot in health
microfinance
education so much to do and the failure
rate of many of these projects will be
very high the ability of these tough
conditions to defeat things that even
you might think would work is is
daunting and yet if we keep trying if we
have the awareness we get out there and
learn about it I think we can do
phenomenal things and so when we think
about why software and all these
technology innovations are magic I I
think we should feel the best about it
if we're making sure it's magic for each
group of 2 billion in the world so I
hope you've gotten a sense of the
incredible optimism I have about the
advances that will be made in fact I
expect a lot of them to be made by the
people here I think you're in this field
that really the the most amazing time
ever and so I'll be fascinated
see the the wonderful things that you do
thank you